okay as always our recordings of our
virtual meetups will be available on
youtube about a week after the meetup
and we will post a message on meetup
when the recording is ready
next i am very pleased to introduce our
speaker today eduardo blancas
eduardo blancas is the co-founder and
ceo of plumber a y combinator back
company developing tools to bridge the
gap between interactive data work and
production
before that he was a data scientist at
fidelity investments where he deployed
the first customer facing machine
learning model for asset management
eduardo holds an ms in data science from
columbia university
so today um our speaker is fine with you
asking questions throughout the talk so
um you also make some stops along the
way of the talk if you want to jump in
just feel free to put something in the
chat and um i'll ask the questions
during one of the stops
okay edward take it away um if you
aren't able to screen share just let me
know because i was changing some of the
settings
okay let me
try to share
i think it's working uh can you see my
slides okay cool uh let me test my
controls okay cool working um hi
everyone thanks a lot for joining today
i'm excited to be presenting
um the talk and um yeah so we are gonna
walk through this there's going to be a
lot of information here uh but i have a
lot of links and uh i'll i'll also share
the url um where you can get these
lights um the important thing is to get
a high level idea and then you can go to
the links that i'm going to share and
like take a deep dive into the resources
all right so let's start um so today we
are going to be talking about running
notebooks in production right maybe you
heard this before um there are a few
companies that do this that run roblox
in production
and i think when i share this with
other data scientists or other
practitioners
many get the idea that this is like
something crazy
and that you should never do it right um
there are good reasons for
not carelessly deploying notebooks into
production but i think it's important to
get into the details like
understand why some people don't like
this idea um
but why there are others who actually
promote these and and why what's what's
the way of promoting this like what's
the reasoning um so we are gonna go
through all these this important stuff
and all these details right um are you
you may if you've been doing data
science or data analytics for a while
um and you have used jupiter notebooks
you know that
if you start working on a notebook
things become a mess really fast right
you start adding a few sales you start
adding some code
and then all of a sudden maybe a few
days of working with your notebook um
it's like 200 sales and then things
break and then you cannot reproduce your
results
but we can actually use jupyter
notebooks in a maintainable way and we
can develop high quality production
ready codes and this is what this talk
will try to convince you about so
hopefully it will
give you the tools to try it by yourself
and see that that it works
now uh before i continue there is
actually a really interesting there's a
really interesting use case from
evidation health a healthcare technology
company they use notebooks in production
and you can see it by yourself
there's there's a link here you can look
at their use case to see a real industry
use case of notebooks in production and
we're going to cover many of the things
that they do in this talk
all right
now before i start there is something
really really important to know because
i feel like
whenever
we whenever the people who
um advocate to run notebooks in
production like me this is like the most
important thing to mention because many
of the discussion turns around this idea
and this fact jupiter is
actually two things it's a file format
and it's a platform
and it's important to study this
from
this angle where we take into account
both um
both parts of the equation
when you are working on a jupiter
notebook you are storing this type of
file this the i py and b format is
actually a json file so when you're
working on a typical jupyter notebook if
you open your notebook with a text
editor it's going to look like this
right
this is a json file with a specific
schema
and
this has some benefits and some
disadvantages one of the main benefits
is that you can
record the output of your code in a
single file then you can share this file
with someone else and then they'll be
able to see your charts everything that
you produce in your notebook without
having to rerun anything because your
notebook contains all of these things in
the same file
now it's also a platform because if you
take a notebook and open that file in
jupyter lab or the classic jupiter
notebooks you'll have all these buttons
and features that allow you to edit this
notebook
the important thing and this is like a
really uh
essential piece that i want to share is
that you can
use this independently and let me
explain that a little bit
one of the
most important tricks to write clean
notebooks and use jupyter notebooks in
production is to just use a different
format and this is something that most
people don't know
um but this is this really changes a lot
of the the ideas
there's this package called jupitext
that allows you to
have different file formats that when
you open them they behave like a
notebook
one of the most popular formats is this
pi file with specific annotations so
this is your typical dot by file except
it has a few extra marks you can see
this
and you can see this
this special marker separates the
notebook the notebook
because this is actually a notebook in
pi format
and this you can use this marker to
separate different cells
right and you can use other forms up
text supports markdown
and many other formats so this this is
very important thing for you to know you
can use alternative formats and then you
can open them as jupiter notes now
what's the main benefit of this
if you're using git
then storing pi files makes things a lot
easier for you because since i mentioned
before the ipi nv format contains output
and many other things that make it a bit
tricky to work with it
it also helps with interoperability
because maybe you like notebooks but
maybe your colleague likes vs code or
spider or pycharm
all these ides can open the same format
so then if you like notebooks you can
open jupyter
change this file and then your colleague
can use vs code and edit the same file
all right
so now let's dive into the details so
this talk is um i split this talk into
three sections the first part is how do
you write clean notebooks how do we keep
the standards high so we are able to
reproduce our code make our code
readable
and make sure that when we come back to
our notebook we understand it now
there's also you'll see that i'm showing
a lot of links and there are a few
recommended reads
there's a longer version of this section
in our blog so you can go to plumber.io
slash blog slash clean
nbs and then you'll see like a longer
version of this
all right so
one of the first properties of clean
notebooks is that they are short if you
have a notebook that has three 400 sales
it's gonna be really really challenging
to maintain so the first thing is keep
your notebook short and follow the same
structure have a standard structure so
you understand what's going on and other
people understand what's going on now
what's that structure i don't want to be
too prescriptive i'm sharing what's been
working for me um through the years but
always if you have questions if you feel
like there's something you can improve
um you can suggest things right that's
that's that's the spirit with all these
practices i'm gonna propose a few things
but maybe a few things don't work for
you so maybe you can you can tweak it a
little bit
okay this is the structure that i follow
with all my notebooks at the beginning i
have all my input statements essentially
all the libraries that i'm going to use
even if i'm using one specific library
at the end of my notebook i put it i put
the import statement at the beginning
the reason is that if i open the
notebook then i'll know what libraries
i'm using
if i put my import statements in the
middle of the notebook then
maybe i'll start executing it and then
i'll realize that i don't have that
library so having these import
statements at the top kind of sets up
expectations of what libraries you are
going to use
the second important thing is the
configuration
often you have to prepare a few things
before running your code
for example if you are connecting to
some database you have to create the
database connection um this is just an
example of other things maybe you are
logging your results it's important to
put all the configuration in the same
place and the reason is the same if you
open a notebook and you see one cell
with all the configuration then you know
what's going on right you know that this
notebook is um communicating with some
database it's logging the experiments to
an external server or any other external
thing that that you need you can put
that here
the next part is
the data loading if we are going to use
jupyter notebooks for for analyzing
clean data we have to load the data at
some point
and i recommend you put this right here
where someone who's reading the notebook
can see
all the data that you are going to use
and then you repeat the same recipe once
you load the data you repeat the same
recipe
for all the sections you have a magnum
heading a magnum heading is just some
text and then
you have some title where you can
quickly explain what's going on by just
one or two words then you can add
some text below to
explain what's gonna what's this section
is gonna do then the takeaways kind of
the conclusion of what this section is
and finally the code so if you follow
this recipe you'll see that the code
becomes a lot clearer and easy to read
okay
now let's move on the second advice that
i have is in terms of the code
let me show you an example because
that's gonna
make things a lot easier let's imagine
that you had you're using pandas really
popular library i'm sure you have used
it many many times
and you have a function right you know
that modularizing your code is important
so you have a function that performs
some transformation in this case that
transformation is taking the serials
column and adding one
like that's all it's doing it simply
adds one
and then you initialize your data you
load your data
so i'm passing um three zeros and naming
this column zeros then assigning it to
this data frame
now imagine you have a bunch of code
maybe a hundred lines of code
and then you have something like this
maybe you remember that your data frame
df has zeros
what happens if we run
this function
look at the implementation
and we are overwriting the values inside
the data frame
and when we print the value
we'll see that this actually contains
once
now this example is really really really
simple but when you have two maybe
200 lines of code it becomes really hard
to understand what's going on and it
might be surprising to you to see that
your data frame contains once instead of
zeros
the problem is that we are modifying
our argument so the argument of this
function is the f
and from here
we don't know if we are modifying df or
we are doing something else
it's unclear what's going on we have to
look at the
implementation and this can cause a lot
of headaches now how do we fix it
well we create immutable code that
doesn't change the arguments
look at the difference between the first
implementation and the second
implementation in the second one we are
copying the data and we are modifying
the copy of the data
so if we initialize our data and we
apply the transformation
once con contains the number one because
we are adding one but df contains zeros
right so if we still remember that we
loaded all serials
all throughout our notebook df will
still contain zeros no surprises
now of course this simple approach is
not feasible when you are dealing with
large data sets because coping data
it's going to add a lot of overhead in
terms of the memory that you need
but for many cases it's it's it works
it's a simple approach that works if you
are dealing with big data sets then
there are other techniques that you can
follow
in order to prevent this kind of
this kind of surprises
great
uh now moving on
one important thing
about your code
is that most likely you're using
external libraries right you might be
using pandas numpy circuit learn
and these libraries change
the scikit learn that you use a month
ago is different from the one that you
get if you download the latest version
many times it will be fine and your code
will just work
but sometimes maintainers have to make
breaking changes
maybe people are suggesting that some
argument is confusing maybe they are
deprecating some apis
this the the bottom line is that
things may break like your notebook may
work fine just now but a few months from
now it will break with the same code
with the same data with different
versions
how do you protect against those those
changes
well you have to record all the versions
that you are using so if you are using
package a 1.1 and package b 2.4 you want
to record all those things
so next time you try to run your code
you recover these
same versions and you run the code
um with them and how do you do that well
once you install all your dependencies
you can run this command
and this is going to auto generate
all these uh lines
all these packages with all these
versions and now let's say uh three
months from now you share your notebook
with a colleague and then you send both
the notebook and this file
if they take this file and then use beep
install they'll be able to recreate your
environment and they will get the same
versions that you had
two three months ago
and you'll make sure that they are able
to run it
now this is like a really really simple
trick that works
um really well it's just one command you
create a file and that's it
and if you change your dependencies
you can run it again to get the the new
changes
all right so we are almost done with the
first section um the latest part is
about the format when we are writing a
bunch of codes
especially in jupiter we may just be
typing things running some experiments
and at some point we are like okay this
is working this is the final version i
i'm gonna move on it onto a different
thing
your code your experimental code may
look like this
right a few lines here and over here and
maybe some white space over here
and it's a bit hard to read like it's
good that you're making those rapid
experiments but if you come back to your
notebook or someone else reads your
notebook
they will have a hard time
trying to understand this right and
making good uh use of white space in the
notebook helps a lot with uh readability
now what you can do
is how to format your notebook meaning
you pass a program
that takes the same code and transform
it to make it more readable it's still
the same code it's going to do the exact
same thing
it just that looks different
look at the example on on your right
it's the same code
except this one is passing one column
a two data frame in one line of code
this should actually be uh c so x y c
and you can read that one line per
column makes a lot of sense because if
you look on the left it's kind of hard
to see
that you are going to create three
columns on your right it's easy to see
that you have x y and this other column
and this is just one of one example of
well what these formatters do for you
the other thing is that if you are and
this is just another specific example if
you are writing some if statements
you may break
the logic into multiple lines by using
the backlash
so the backslash you can put it here and
then you can break down this if
statement into multiple lines
it's a bit harder to read and you can
use parentheses for that so if you out
to format these things
you'll see that it automatically fits
this into a single line and if it's a
long if statement it will automatically
break break it down with parenthesis
which is a lot more readable
now we don't have time to do these
things manually right we just want to
get things
working and then move on you can use
this package that we are developing
and it will automatically do the
formatting for you
um this uh standard for formatting is
called black it's um
official
package um a package that
many many people in the python community
uses um we just grabbed a wrapper that
makes it possible to use this formatter
in jupyter notebooks
all right
now
the last section the last part of this
section is
splitting logic from narrative the idea
with notebooks is that you are telling a
story about your data you are
transforming your data you are cleaning
your data
and you are essentially doing a recipe
right step one step two step three
now some steps in that recipe might be
more complex than others
so we can split the code
into two different types the first one
is the logic
functions that encapsulate some steps
some logic and classes
that
encapsulate some some logic
and the narrative the narrative are all
the plots all the chains of
transformations and the story that we
are telling about our data
now if we split this into two things
become a lot more readable because if
someone
opens your notebook and they see the
story they can quickly understand what's
going on at a high level for example you
can see that i'm loading some data here
and then i'm adding one i don't know
exactly what's the implementation of
this function but based on the name
i cannot guess what's going on
and then
i can split my logic my functions in a
separate file
so i have a transformations.pi and i and
then i import these transformations.pi
into my notebook
so this display helps a lot for you
because you can test
the logic separately
and also for your readers because you're
able to open the notebook and see
kind of the story so it's a little a
little bit of extra work because you
have to create a new file you have to
move your code into that separate file
but you'll see that um
you'll be able to create cleaner
notebooks and your code will be a lot
more readable
all right so that's the end of the first
section
now let's talk about testing notebooks
this
testing notebooks is a lot more
challenging that you would expect
because
most of the time we are analyzing data
and if we analyze data and the data
changes
the the code may break right so we have
to take into account both the data and
the code
now if you are interested in taking a
deep dive into these two topics we have
two blog posts and i have the links
right here
let's start with i'm gonna mention three
types of tests and those have different
objectives the first one is testing
outputs
when you run your notebooks some of the
cells may generate outputs
for example here i am training the model
and then i'm printing the accuracy of
that model so you see that this is 0.963
now imagine that i make a few changes to
my data set or my transformations and
then
this turns out to be 0.8
if i'm running things manually
i'm going to be surprised
i'm going to be surprised that this
changed too much and then
i think this this this change is worth
investigating
um
when i'm analyzing data and see these
radical changes
i usually
go back and analyze my code see what i
change
and try to come up to a conclusion right
maybe it's right maybe maybe i just
added some data and my accuracy dropped
or maybe not maybe i introduced some
change
but this manual process takes a lot of
time
so we have a new package this is
something that we are working on an open
source package called mb snapshot that
allows you to capture these outputs
historically essentially every time you
run your notebook you can record
some outputs
and then you can we can define an
expected range
in a normal let's think about this
accuracy score if you train your the
same model with the same data but
slightly different parameters
or maybe you have some randomness in
your code
it's expected for these results to
change just a little bit so we use that
we use that variation and take it into
account to define unexpected range
so if your value falls inside that range
it's all good you can run your notebook
and it will be fine
if it falls
out of the range then you'll see an
error and then you'll have the change
chance to investigate what's going on so
it's a way to automate
the manual checks that we still do
um when we are running our code
so this is the first uh the first type
of testing testing the cell out the cell
outputs
now the second one is highly affiliated
because
in some cases you are printing some
values like here
but in other cases you might be creating
new files
right
if you create new files it's important
to also test
those files
and the most important example here is
data quality tests so let's imagine that
you have a notebook and you are
you're cleaning some data
and then you store that clean data into
a file
maybe you're making some assumptions
about what clean data means maybe for
you the definition of clean data is that
column
is that a specific column doesn't have
any nas
or maybe that it doesn't have any
negative numbers that depends on your
project and the expectations that you
have about the data
and as you can see testing is all about
automation i have those expectations but
it's best to make sure
that those expectations are true
every time i run my notebook that's the
idea with testing the outputs of your
notebook
once you run your notebook you can have
a function like this and check the
output of the notebook
for example here i'm checking that the
column doesn't have any nas
and that the column doesn't have any
negative numbers
now if something changes here i want to
know because maybe the data changed or
maybe i changed my code and i made some
mistake
you can embed this logic into your
notebook or you can use library we also
have a library called plumber which
allows you to do this essentially having
data quality tests and they run after
you run your notebook so it's a it's a
way of automating um these checkings
all right i'm gonna stop for a few
seconds in case anyone has any questions
okay looks like we're good you'll still
have time to ask me questions at the end
okay
uh now testing notebooks
as i mentioned before let me go back to
here sometimes we have to define
encapsulate some logic maybe you have a
few functions or classes that
encapsulate some logic
we have to test those as well to make
sure that they are working as we expect
them to do
so there are two approaches here
if you split as i mentioned
the narrative
from the logic
then you can import
your logic into a separate file
and then test the implementation this is
approach that i recommend because it
allows you to test things in isolation
and then it also allows you to import
your functions
in any other notebooks and reuse them
right you define them in a single place
and then you bring them to your tests
you bring them to your notebooks and you
only use
um one single definition
if you want to implement this you can
use bytest
now there are other approaches as well
if you define if you don't split the
functions from your notebook which is
also fine if you are working on a small
project
and the whole analysis fits well into a
single notebook it's fine to define
those functions
i think
the most important
part of organizing your code is
to see what works for you in your
specific use case so i actually
sometimes define
functions inside my notebooks if i know
that i only need that function for that
specific notebook and maybe i'm running
some simple analysis
so if that applies to you
and you are embedding your functions
inside the notebook you can follow this
second approach
so this library is called textbook
testbook and
it's kind of similar to the other
approach except
you tell the library
where's the notebook that you want to
test so let's assume is this path to nv
dot py and b i pi nb
and then this lobby allows you to
extract certain function
from the notebook so i'm telling this
library
to get me the add1 function inside the
notebook
now this returns me this function and
then i can test it
right it's also it's a good approach if
you already have some
legacy code some existing notebook this
is a good way to get started and add
some tests to your notebooks and this
library has like other features to it
nice
and and you can you can check it out
all right so now uh we are going to
start talking about the
the third section which is building data
pipelines
again if you want to take a deep dive
into the details you can look at our
blog from the dot io slash blog
slash clean dash pipelines and and
you'll get more of these details now
before
in one of the previous section i
explained
that
having short notebooks helps you a lot
to make sure that you can maintain that
code and it doesn't have too much logic
now you might be wondering
how can i come up with a short notebook
if my analysis needs lots of different
parts
well the solution is to build a data
pipeline a data pipeline is essentially
breaking down
the whole data analysis logic into
multiple pieces and then
modifying those pieces in isolation and
making sure that those pieces are able
to communicate with each other
so let's go with the first scenario
where you have all your logic in a
single file maybe it's called
analysis.ip now one important thing is
remember that at the beginning of the
presentation i mentioned that you can
use pi files as notebooks using jupytext
now this this same logic applies if you
have an ipi md file a pi file or a
markdown file the same logic applies
okay so let's say you have a really
knock notebook that has 2 200 cells
it becomes really hard to maintain
you can represent the same notebook in
multiple small pieces
for example instead of analysis you may
have a load notebook a clean notebook
and a plot notebook
instead of having 200 cells you may be
able to split them into smaller chunks
and at the end of the notebook you store
a file the next notebook loads that file
and then the final notebook loads the
second file
now you can see that by breaking down
this logic it's easier to understand
what's going on because if you show this
to some colleague and they see this they
understand that you have three different
parts and if they are interested in
something specific they can just open
that part
and they don't have to read the other
details that might not be relevant at
the moment
now the the other important thing is
that
by breaking down these logic into
multiple files you are bringing
some kind of complexity to your project
because you have to manage multiple
files right that's
that's
why having long notebooks is
sometimes convenient because you just
keep adding code and code and code and
it's convenient because you have
everything there
um but it comes with a lot of
disadvantages so if you break down the
logic you're yeah you're adding a few a
few new files a few extra logic to store
those files and then load them in the
next notebook
but you'll see that it pays in the long
run now to make it easier for you to
build these kinds of things you can use
our library it's open source
and if you already have legacy notebooks
that look like this you can use another
library that we are working on that
automatically takes this
and converts that into a pipeline so you
save a lot of time you don't have to go
through your code and then create a new
file and copy paste this will do it for
you and then you can start working with
multiple small pieces
all right so um
that's that's all i have um one quick
announcement we are running a free
online course a longer version of this
presentation with a lot lot many things
that i didn't cover
um you can sign up here
and
you'll learn many many many many tricks
to be able to run a notebooks in
production now if you are interested in
getting these lights you can go to this
url and you'll be able to download them
um so that's that's the
that's all i have i i hope this is
useful and you learn a few tricks and
now you are able to create a lot more
maintainable code and you are able to
deploy those notebooks into production
and it makes things easier for you
and now if you have any questions maybe
maybe right now they don't come up maybe
tomorrow you can always reach out to me
i'm happy to chat happy to help you
refactor some notebooks or think how you
can apply these practices to your
projects so here's my email feel free
to reach out to me so now um
feel free to ask me any questions
yeah feel free to
put a question in the chat or a request
to mute yourself to ask a question um
i'll bite a little time in case people
are still thinking
um eduardo thank you so much um
we had you i think around this time last
year as well
it's really cool to see how
your work has progressed um i think you
didn't have y combinator at that time
yeah so it's really encouraging to see
the progress in this work
yeah it's it's exciting um last year i
was still part-time working on plumber
part-time like just on the weekends and
the evenings and now i'm able to work on
it this on this project full-time
uh so it's pretty exciting because we
can implement features a lot faster we
can come up with new ideas um and yeah
it's great it's great too to share the
updates with with the pi data community
hey uh yeah i see ravi has their hand up
so eduardo
thanks for the presentation
i have a quick question
how can you incorporate ml flow in
notebooks uh generally people do that in
the python files but can you do that
like an ml flow framework in notebooks
yes that's a that's a great question
we have an example so let me re-share my
screen
[Music]
i don't think i have this specific link
but anyway you can you can go to github
and then find
our organization so github dot com slash
bloomberg slash projects we have tons of
examples one of those examples is
integrating bloomberg with emerald flow
and it you can download it and run it
now how it works um it essentially let
me see if i find some i think this
diagram is gonna be useful yeah so
imagine you have um a notebook that
trains a model right let's say it's your
last notebook at the end
you can use these yeah exactly so
bloomer has this feature that allows you
to run a function after you execute one
notebook now for this this specific use
case i am checking data quality
but the logic can be anything so if you
look at the code you'll see that what we
have is a function so you have your
notebook you train a model and then you
run a function
that function takes
the
performance of the model the model file
and it uploads it to ml flow so
essentially you can split the codes you
can split your logic into two parts the
notebook that trains the model and the
function that runs after you execute the
model that stores everything into
another flow
great thank you yep
okay any other questions
i think we do have some time
yeah one from the chat um tony asked do
you schedule your notebooks
yep um so i we don't have any
scheduling feature in bloomberg
what you can do is export
your if you use plumber if you use
plumber you can export it to airflow and
you can use the airflow scheduler or you
can use chrome now if you are using um
just a notebook there are a few
libraries that allow you to schedule
notebooks like one thing is you can take
that notebook wrapping into an airflow
pipeline with a single task and use
airflow
or you can use chrome as well
and you can use paper mail papermill
allows you to execute single notebooks
and then you can call that library like
every day
we actually use um paper mill under the
hood um for for plumber so it it works
the same
but essentially since running notebooks
is running one command any scheduler
that allows you to run some bash
commands
will work and then you can define what
you do after the execution typically
what teams do is they execute the
notebook and then they store the
executed notebook into some storage like
s3 or mflow and then you can
review that those results later
okay anyone else
okay well thank you so much edwardo for
coming back to us and showing your work
uh as a reminder everyone this is a
monthly virtual meetup um and we
generally meet the last thursday yeah
last thursday uh of the month so keep an
eye out on our meetup page for future
meetups
all right good evening
thanks a lot
bye